you know one thing I've developed an
irrational fear for recently this can
sound so stupid out of context go on
Infinity
call this episode now we have an
existential cross why why why why okay
okay explain okay in layman's terms why
you are afraid of infinity I think okay
so I've you know I've talked about being
getting to like a lot of like videos in
terms like physics and like I guess it
just sounds like you've watched one too
many Vsauce videos it's not it's not a
Vsauce video it's actually a uh it's
actually a documentary I saw that the
BBC did on the concept of infinity
because I've it's fast I find it like
fascinating personally that
uh infinity as a concept is a something
that you can explain to like a
five-year-old you know but it's when you
really think about what it actually
means do you kind of like the more you
think about it the more you fail to
grasp what Infinity actually is like
what's the biggest number you can think
of like what's what's the biggest number
you can at Googleplex a Googleplex yeah
like you think of like a Googleplex
which is what's what's the uh Guy what's
the exact definition
[Music]
is 10 to the power of 100 yeah Google is
10 to the power of 100 so it's one with
a hundred zeros on the end right
um so if you think about a Googleplex
right you cannot even write if you if
you take the one and put every zero on
an atom in the Googleplex you will run
out of space in the entire observable
universe before you can literally before
you can even write out a Googleplex yeah
and that number is a [__] tiny number
compared to like Infinity yeah right it
it is Tiny it's it's Infinity as a
concept if you really really think about
it you know the biggest number I can
think of off the top of my head and this
is now this is how you know I've gone
down a rabbit hole is is this concept
called tree three right and if you even
try to fit three if you try even try to
fit three into the observable universe
if you take the smallest unit of
measurement in the observable universe
Plankton which is a plank distant and
divide that in the entire space of the
universe
you will have to compress like you could
you have to compress information so
densely that you will turn the entire
universe into a black hole
[__] and still that is a tiny [__]
number and like the more you think about
it the more you're just like
holy [__] this is yeah yeah it's
infinite right it's easy to say it's
infinite but the more you think about it
the more you like
the more you like holy [__] this is this
is something that you cannot even come
close not even not even minutely
comprehend what Infinity actually means
and then I think about it and I'm like
[__] me that is terrifying just to think
that humans have invented a concept that
can make ourselves feel so insignificant
and yet it's like and yeah uh [__]
child can understand so what does the
number scare you sorry what is the
number scale I think it's the concept
why does it scare you sorry why does
that scare you it's just like you just
makes you realize it's because it's like
he's gonna try and write the number out
go on it's not gonna work
it's it's the concept it's the concept
it's it's the it's the like I said
that's the that's kind of like the
feeling of existential horror that I
love it's it's the concept of it right
this makes sense because this is
probably why you play ganshin because it
doesn't know how many [__] gachapoles
you do that that is [__] lovecraftian
horror man I know I know how you feel
because I got into that similar well I
got into that similar kind of rabbit
hole a while back yeah I was like what
are you guys doing well because I
because I watch a lot of like math and
like physics videos yeah I'm a [__]
nerd yeah but I I remember like this
will blow your mind think about it like
this there are an infinite amount of
numbers right like finite numbers one
two three four five six seven yeah there
are the same amount of infinite numbers
between zero and one
yeah
and because if you get if you're trying
to write out right zero to one yeah
what's the next number that comes after
zero zero point zero zero zero zero zero
zero so it's just an infinite number of
zeros and then somewhere at the end
there's a one not on my calculator
do I know it's something even more
[__] gone [__] mind blown are we
are we giving each other Infinity yeah
yeah we are we are giving each other
infinity facts Mark Connor loses mine
right go on there are Infinities that
are bigger than other Infinity yeah I
know I've seen it at this yeah they have
like the infinity to the power of two
Infinity yeah yeah you're like okay
which is still Infinity I'm I'm like
it's gotten to the point where
mathematics has evolved to a point where
we can give ourselves well they need to
figure out what the odds were of Hunter
Hunter for being finished
[Music]
that's a that's a number lower than uh
any number that's ever been written in
the in the [__] Universe we can wait
till the end of the universe until now
she's late yeah no I want a [__]
horror movie around the concept of
infinity they'll be [__] that sounds
like a really [__] M Night shy actually
that would be it that sounds awesome
infinity I'm not funding this movie no
one else is
housewife finds out that she's uh in
infinite a number away from [__]
finding her husband and